the biggest beef i have with him or
really
the biggest beef is over natural
immunity
his pushing to force children to be
vaccinated is based on his assumption
that natural immunity doesn't count and
when you ask him about it as cnn asked
him once in the last month they said
what about natural immunity says oh
that would be interesting wow we should
look into that as if the the subject had
never crossed his mind but that's just
one more lie and a list of lies
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
anthony fauci's worst nightmare as well
as the senator from the great state of
kentucky senator rand paul welcome back
to the reuben report
thanks for having me glad to be with you
i know we're tight on time here so we're
only going to knock out two topics we're
going to talk fouchy
and inflation everyone's seen some of
the brouhahas between you guys where
where are you at with fouchy
and mandates and and trust in science
and all of it at this point
well i think the biggest problem is that
he has a casual disregard for individual
liberty but he also has a casual
disregard for the science as well you
add those together and it's sort of a
recipe for authoritarianism and that's
basically what he is as an authoritarian
so lately the biggest beef i have with
him or really
the biggest beef is over natural
immunity his pushing to force children
to be vaccinated is based on his
assumption that natural immunity doesn't
count and when you ask him about it as
cnn asked him once in the last month
they said what about natural immunity he
says oh
that would be interesting wow we should
look into that as if the the subject had
never crossed his mind but that's just
one more lie and a list of lies he
obviously knows about natural immunity
in fact when they do the studies on
children for vaccines they exclude
children who've already had coveted
that's why we don't know whether it's
safe for kids who have already had covet
because they're not in the studies why
does he exclude them from the studies
because they've got natural immunity and
they would confound the study so he's
dishonest at every level
so between natural immunity the origins
of the virus the mask wearing at every
step of the way i think he's been
dishonest to people
mainly because he believes in the bigger
truth the collective truth he believes
that it's okay to lie to the people
because the people are ignorant and need
to be told what to do by an authority
like himself and uh basically that's a
recipe for authoritarianism
so as more and more of the stuff that
you've been talking about for a year
with fouchy comes out do you think he
will ever pay a price politically or
have to step down or anything i mean i
think one of the reasons people are so
frustrated is they see that these people
lie constantly they get caught in the
lies and nothing ever happens to them
well the interesting thing is is history
his name is tarnished in history and his
reputation is tarnished i would say his
reputation is in tatters now the
left-wing media still likes him and
treats him with kid gloves but if you
actually look at the numbers probably
when he first came out in march of that
year and he sounded like a reasonable
scientist probably 95 percent of people
trusted him we've polled it in our state
less than half the people trust him
less than half of people in kentucky
actually trust what he's saying so that
he's come down quite a bit here he's
still a menace though he's still a
menace to individual liberty every day
because if you've seen he even gets out
in front of the biden administration now
saying well i don't know what they're
going to do but i would ban travel but
see none of it's based on science
because now we know that those who have
been vaccinated can catch it and can
transmit it so to punish the
unvaccinated because somehow they're the
danger when everybody's at risk for this
frankly everybody's at risk for catching
it everybody's at risk for passing it
but frankly only certain segments of the
population are at risk for being
hospitalized and dying from this for the
most part those who are younger are not
at risk and one of the biggest things
i've been pushing back with lately is
that the whole country of sweden 1.8
million children have not worn masks at
all in the last year
zero deaths and among teachers the same
amount of illness as the rest of the
public so no increased illness for
teachers and zero deaths among children
wearing no masks why don't we look at
the science
how elated were you when we got this
court order that the mandate for
companies with is was it a hundred or a
thousand employees i think 100 employees
100 employees yep that that this is
basically on pause at least for now
partly because of the lawsuit involving
the daily wire uh led by my friend
harmeet dillon i mean we got some good
news this week it's rare but we got some
good news
absolutely the fifth circuits put a stay
on it which is important no one has to
adhere to it when january 4th comes with
the stay on it osha will not enforce it
so every small business person listening
this you do not have to adhere to it
until the court rules again
they've consolidated the cases and it's
going to the 6th circuit which is in
cincinnati has many kentucky judges that
have been appointed
in recent years under the trump
administration by republican congress we
think that we will get a fair hearing in
the sixth court our hope is that it goes
all the way to the supreme court and
they nullify this thing
the interesting irony of this is it may
be that the obamacare ruling is the
precedent for making this
unconstitutional you remember with
obamacare they said you can't force
people to buy insurance under the
commerce clause but then they twist
twisted and themselves into a pretzel
and says oh you can do it under the
taxation clause
osha and the mandate are under the
commerce clause so it may well be that
the precedent of saying obamacare was
unconstitutional under the commerce
clause may be why they strike this
vaccine mandate as also being
unconstitutional
so one more thing on this and then we'll
move to inflation are the courts sort of
your last hope at this point that our
executive branch obviously right now is
completely out of control the
legislative branch seems either
completely broken or unable to really do
anything or completely ignored are the
courts the the hope is that what we
should all be pinning our hope on
this should show people the danger of
handing the entire government over to
the democrats because they've got the
presidency both houses of congress and
so yeah our only hope is in the courts
or holding them off until 2022 but i
will say that people shouldn't get
discouraged moral outrage on the
internet on your program you don't ever
get outraged do you well let's say you
do one's on again
but the thing is is moral outrage is
having some influence on democrats when
people got really angry about people
looking at their check accounts if 600
went through guess what they pulled that
from the bill
people right now are hopping mad about
450 000 being given to immigrant
families that came across and were
separated people think that's insane and
my guess is they will eventually pull
back on that on the mandate well
opinions are mixed in the country on
vaccines
on mandating it and taking someone's job
if they don't adhere to the mandate only
14 of america supports that
so we're getting ready to have a vote
we're forcing it's called a privileged
vote on repealing this law in congress
we got all 50 republicans in the senate
to sign on to it now so what's going to
happen is there's going to be a lot of
outrage i mean the biggest economic
damage from this rule will happen in
west virginia we had an economist crunch
the numbers and because west virginia
has a high number of unvaccinated folks
and a high number of employers that have
over 100 they will be economically hurt
worse than any country any other state
in the union maybe that'll influence if
we get another democrat we then defeat
the regulation
unfortunately biden will veto it but
it'll look awful if the majority of
congress actually votes to veto his rule
and then he has to overrule it all right
so let's shift to inflation for the
remaining time uh you know if you listen
to jen saki and joe biden and pete
budage the reason that we can't get
things uh you know in stores and that
everything is slow right now and it
takes six months to get a couch and
money doesn't seem to have the value is
because we're all buying so much stuff
that they just can't make it fast enough
that seems to be the meme that they're
putting out i sense you don't agree with
that
well i'm afraid this is an indictment of
our school system these people have
complete and utter ignorance
uh we borrowed nearly four trillion
dollars last year we have inflation this
year of six percent that's what it's
from borrowing money and then the
federal reserve prints money more money
in circulation bids prices up the money
loses its value per unit
it there there's no clearer explanation
than that there's no way they can but
what is their response oh we need to
borrow more money it has nothing to do
with borrowing money so
this is a real problem but i don't think
you can fool all the people all the time
frankly people go to the grocery store
and i think they are sensing that there
is some culpability if not complete
culpability with the biden
administration so we'll see what happens
but i think people are turning sour the
victory in in virginia and the near
victory in new jersey this shows a wave
of dis discontent that is rising up and
you know biden basically lied to the
american people he was going to be a
unifier he was going to be a moderate he
was going to work with
republicans they're pushing forward
thing for which there is no republican
support zero republican support so i
think what you're going to find is the
the electorate's going to be very very
upset by 2022 and there's going to be a
big reversal
senator i just want to understand this
and i've got pen and paper here are you
telling me that 3.5 trillion does not
equal zero
there's a little bit of problem with the
math there i've heard of new math and i
know in california they add up things
differently but yeah 3.5 trillion is 3.5
trillion that's what it'll cost and if
they take that money out of the economy
through taxes that's 3.5 trillion that
was being used usefully and voted on by
the consumer and you put it into
politicians wish list and it'll be used
less effectively or if you borrow it you
create inflation either way it's not a
good idea
and to tie it all together i'm fairly
certain that anthony fauci is the
highest paid person in the federal
government right over 420 grand if i'm
not mistaken so they're definitely
making some mistakes senators
very soon
absolutely senator always a pleasure
you're welcome back anytime
thank you if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell